Male: Enamel paints are
essentially household paints
or automotive paints,
and they've been used
by artists for a long
time as early as well,
Pablo Picasso.
In the early 20th century many abstract
expressionist painters used it, but enamel
is a tricky term because
it doesn't really tell you
what type of paint you're talking about,
but rather the properties of that paint.
There is alkyd enamel paints.
There is acrylic enamel paint.
There are latex enamel paints.
It just means that actually
the paint is quite fluid
and you can see that it
has a very low viscosity
as I'm pouring it from the can here.
It also means that the paint has a high
covering power.
So, that for consumers
at home painting walls
one coat should do the
trick so you shouldn't see
brush strokes and things
like that on your wall.
It also means that the
paint is self leveling,
very, very flat.
Usually dries to a hard,
often glossy finish.